hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the next bit robin and it's supposed
to be the smartphone that never runs out
of storage at least that's what they
claim so as a new 400 smartphone this
thing is actually really interesting
anytime you get an entire phone made by
a brand new company there's some
decisions that have to be made to put it
on the map and the robin is no exception
so next bit robin is this very squared
off rectangular phone with tight corners
it kind of looks a little uncomfortable
at first but it has a sort of soft touch
finish and it actually feels really good
in the hand it has a decent balance of
weight it's got well fitted parts and
it's durable enough that it feels like
you could hurt someone with this thing
so it's well built it feels good you've
got your power button on the right hand
side which is also a fingerprint reader
and your tiny volume buttons on the left
hand side i think these might be the
worst part of the build the buttons are
small with very little travel and then
the power button on the right it doesn't
protrude at all so it can be kind of
hard to tell which side is up without
looking the fingerprint reader is
actually really good though the speed
and accuracy are on point and pro tip
with the side placement like this i
actually kind of like it you can have
two fingers registered your left index
finger and
your right thumb for the way you grip
the phone anyway usb type c at the
bottom left corner
with a quick charging light and on the
front dual stereo front-facing speakers
i love this they're loud and clear so
that's awesome for gaming listening to
music and watching videos etc the great
choice there now from here you can pick
it up and use it kind of just like a
normal 400 android smartphone it's
running the latest version of android
6.0 and it's a custom next bit skin
which we'll get to in a second but a lot
of the elements still feel pretty stock
so like the notifications the lock
screen the quick settings etc the specs
are pretty good too snapdragon 808 three
gigabytes of ram
and a 2
680 milliamp hour battery i'd say the
performance to the specs were up to par
pretty smooth throughout which is an
occasional force close or a weird
storage problem but the battery life was
a little worse i was getting like three
and a half hours of screen on time which
is less than i expected out of a 5.2
inch 1080p display the 13 megapixel
camera on the back was decent kind of
reminded me of the blackberry priv
camera actually so colors out of it were
fine and detail was fine but dynamic
range was a little weak so a lot of
stuff got overexposed but overall solid
for the budget just a little slow to
actually take the photos in the custom
nexbit camera app as you can see that
shutter lag is real but so how is this
the phone that doesn't run out of
storage well all the magic is buried
here in the next bit skin so every
nexbit robin comes with 32 gigs of
onboard storage but then also 100 gigs
of free cloud storage now right off the
bat that's not unlimited but whatever
that's a lot more than 32 gigs and then
the robin is supposed to be smart enough
and it is to offload the oldest and
least frequently used stuff from the
internal storage straight to the cloud
when it hasn't been accessed in a while
so when you start to fill the 32
gigabytes old apps and old photos that
haven't been opened in a while will move
to the cloud and make room for more and
the idea is for that to happen
seamlessly almost without you ever
having a notice now this is the next bit
launcher and as you can see here all
these app icons there is no app drawer
so all of your apps here are spread
across all your home screens and we can
talk about whether we like that or not
in another video but that's the way it's
set up so you can tap an app if you want
to get into it and it opens right up now
you may have noticed some of the icons
are grayed out so these are the apps
that are offline or in the cloud and
they're not stored on the device anymore
when you click on them it takes a minute
to download everything in the state you
last left it in and then it opens up
right where you left off and it takes a
good second even on solid wi-fi but this
archiving and restoring process is the
big selling point for the robin now if
there are apps you use all the time that
you don't want to get archived you can
swipe down on the icon to pin them
pinned apps never go to the cloud
they're pinned on the device forever of
course if you're using it all the time
you shouldn't even need to pin them it
shouldn't accidentally get archived if
you use it a lot
but yeah that's it that's the secret to
robin never running out of storage now
for a 400 phone having potentially 132
gigs of storage is cool but it's also
dependent on the internet and buying
into that next bit system and i almost
wouldn't buy this phone just for this
feature in fact i'd buy this phone just
for the fact that at its price it's
actually a pretty solid android
smartphone and you can ignore all the
nexbid stuff and just use it like a
normal phone toss on your launcher of
choice you can root it rom it the
bootloader is actually unlocked out the
box and they'll support loading cyan
engine mod on it or something and they
still honor the warranty so this is like
a good phone for the price outside of
their storage solution now if you were
buying a mid-range phone specifically
focusing on having lots of storage i'd
look at something with a micro sd card
slot like maybe the oneplus x because
you can go past 132 gigs but if that's
not hugely important and you're choosing
between this and something like nexus 5x
or oneplus 2 it's definitely worth
considering this the build quality is up
to par the specs and performance are
pretty solid and the user experience
isn't too crazy and obviously you can
change it the way you like it now i'll
say this if this were a normal 400
vanilla android smartphone with a micro
sd card slot instead of the next bit
cloud stuff it might have been a hit but
it's cool to see this type of
cloud-based storage solution
in action props to next bit i like it
thanks for watching guys and i'll talk
to you guys in the next one
peace